[Music]
[Music]
let let me welcome you all here this
evening and Bill Mitchell and Dean of
the School of Architecture and planning
the occasion this evening is that that
causes this this talk to take place is
the opening of a new space in the School
of Architecture and planning that
includes a magnificent recent work by
frank stella lulu made available to an
MIT very generously by elliott walk and
we've worked over the weekend to get it
all ready to open today
and sure enough things got finished just
in time and the space julie did open
it's in building seven it's room I had
to check this just before I came up here
to talk it's it's room seven three three
six right am I correct on this yes yes I
am correct at seven three three six we
haven't put the number on the door yet
so I have to be careful that I give you
the right number on this it's not open
this evening but as of tomorrow it will
be open to the public and I encourage
everybody to come and take a look at
this piece it's a it's a magnificent
piece and a great room and it will also
bring you into the heart of the rebuilt
headquarters space for the department of
architecture in the department of urban
planning in the school department of
urban studies and planning in the school
of architecture and planning and it also
includes a really interesting new
exhibition space that we intend to make
very active use of so we welcome you all
to that space and very much look forward
to seeing you all there let me make a
very brief introduction to what we're
going to do this evening to anyone who's
interested in painting or in thinking
about painting or in the theorizing of
painting frank stella really truly needs
no introduction so I am going to be
brief born in 1936 a Boston area native
educated at Phillips Andover in at
Princeton for four decades he's been
producing series after series of
astonishingly inventive and
thought-provoking explorations of what
non figurative painting can be and can
become
he's had all sorts of extraordinary
twists and turns in the directions that
he's taken confounded and astonished the
critics at times that has been
unfailingly thought-provoking and really
pushing the envelope pushing the edges
of what painting can be in the wake of
the heyday of abstract expressionism in
the 50s he began to produce as many of
you know his black painting series this
was followed by the aluminum and copper
paintings and the shaped canvases
breaking out of the rectangular plane he
moved into painted metal reliefs in the
70s later huge 3-dimensional pieces in
the Moby Dick series and beyond
and explorations that that's continued
until now and has given us Lou who lose
the piece that will and will be able to
see later on he's moved back and forth
from rigorously precise execution to sly
Phillipe playful improvisation from
straight lines and flat polygons to the
curves with spatial readings of the
exotic bird series he's been an
innovator in fabrication technique and
in in in the means of making of
executing paintings as you'll see later
on in his Norton lectures at Harvard a
decade ago he produced a sustained
theoretical exploration of the aims and
means of paintings that deserves reading
and rereading we're going to have a
conversation about mostly recent work
we're going to sit over here on the
stage and just talk about the the slides
as they come up I have to tell you it's
completely unrehearsed and at Hoek we
just looked at the slides a few minutes
ago and we're going to do our best to
make this this interesting for you but I
think it will be just before we start
what I'd like to do to give you an idea
of what we've been going through in
pulling this extraordinary piece of work
into the MIT context forget to show you
a video of the work arriving at MIT and
in particular some extraordinarily
skillful crane operators maneuvering at
him through the window of building 9 now
I saw some of this happening I haven't
seen the video so so let's take a look
and see what happened as this
my tea
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Thanks it is that all wrong okay I'm
gonna do I can't resist a blackboard so
I'm gonna draw I mean I'm not gonna draw
I'm gonna write a few words on the
blackboard and then we can start showing
the slides and and go on from there you
know there are basically two questions
that I get asked over and over and over
again you know one why did you change
into what's what's going on
today why I change that I really don't
have an answer to that except you know
it's obvious I mean it you just you keep
going
but what's going on today which is a way
of talking about what we just saw in the
video clip I just like to run by you as
simply as I can you know the way I see
what's happening say now you know that
you know what's day I'm not going to
define what the art of the nineties is
but it's interesting to see or at least
to talk about what what's happening and
what not just I'm thinking about but
really what everybody else is thinking
about and it's pretty easy to explain it
or to make a very simplified version of
it and so it really consists of two
things and so what you have today is you
have a painting alright so if you have
painting I know you all know that that's
painting but but it doesn't have to be
just painting it's really art to today
so because you're making art and most of
its going to be can be painting it could
be other things but it breaks down into
two things which is we have literalism
it's a horrible word but it's the best
one and we have illusionism okay and we
used to have problems like abstraction
and representation ilysm but that
doesn't really matter I mean you know we
have a hundred years of that and it
break it it's come now in the 90s or at
the end of the century to this kind of
way of seeing things so they don't
necessarily have to conflict but they
they represent two different polls or
they represent maybe two different ideas
but they all revolve around the same
thing which is that in order to do
anything you have to have you have to
deal with boundaries okay I don't know
what I like spelling these I just like
writing with the chart and to see if I
can spell hey boundaries and you have
surface okay and that's what you're
going to see a lot of and in the slides
and those are the kinds of things that
I'm going to talk about a lot in what
you saw in the video you can already see
how much it's about surface and how much
it's about boundaries and you can see
that if it were just what it is when you
see the backside of the piece that would
be the literal part I mean that might be
good enough it might be a Henry Moore it
might be a might be a minimalist
structure it could be in steel and be a
Richard Serra and do quite well but it
has something else which is the painting
which is the surface that I worked on
anyway it's it's involved with illusion
or illusionism and that's what brings it
back towards painting and the literalism
doesn't exclude painting but it's that
sometimes that it's a conflict and so
we'll go basically from there looking at
the slide see how I got to it and what
other things it leads to basically it
what the conclusion is going to be or
what you might come to as a conclusion
yourself when we get through looking at
the slides is that art in the end will
pass through all of these things through
literalism illusionism boundaries and
surface basically and we'll end up by
defining art is something that you
already knew what it was there which is
it's going to be painting sculpture and
architecture so it won't be a surprise
to you but but that's what the fine arts
are and what happens is a lot of the
divisions and different ways that we
have of looking at things have to do
with the kind of not necessarily
confounding but they have to do with
people taking positions in relation to
these things in which they want to have
their own thing or find that the thing
that they do best
the better thing but we're not going to
really worry about that we're just going
to see how they can come together and we
don't know how they're going to I
certainly don't know how it's going to
happen but you can see in the work that
I'm doing that they do relate to each
other and they do become involved I'm
not saying that a synthesis is a great
idea but you can see at least our eye
can see that there are some
possibilities for kind of synthesis
there would be interesting and that's
why I change a lot of people the piece
on the left I made it and over in 1953
or 54 and it's the Brooklyn Bridge
believe it or not and a lot of people
think that I painted the Brooklyn Bridge
but that was Joseph Stella and we're not
related so actually the kind of
opportunity to sort of lay that one to
rest when I first came to New York a lot
of people said that they were quite
surprised to see what a young man I was
I mean I wasn't that surprised I was
young and the picture on the left is a
painting which is very typical for the
time it's a kind of abstract
expressionist painting I mean it seems
to me actual it might be predate al
Lesley some of his paintings a little
bit that way but very much like mother
well Leslie pretty much kind of second
or you know abstract expressionist
painting but you know the people that I
was most influenced probably in this
painting were mother well and godly and
it was called interestingly enough it
had a title and the title came out of a
New York Post headline but anyway that
painting was called requiem for Johnny
Stompanato and I'm sure that no one here
really remembers who Johnny Stompanato
was but he was a hood who came to an
unfortunate end with Lana turd his
adopted daughter when she stabbed him in
the kitchen
okay we can go yeah that was the last
kind of painting on the left that I made
before I made the black paintings so you
can see the transition from the painting
of Johnny Stompanato painting and and
really it's a landscape and the real
change is pretty straightforward and
pretty simple it's it happened by
painting out you can see that there was
a structure underneath and that there
was a painting it was formed with bands
and blocks and you can see that
somewhere the frustration occurred and
things were and then it got painted out
but it got painted out in such a way
that it became a whole painting and that
idea of painting at all yellow are
painting over the other painting and
making the bands carry the whole thing
is what made the black paintings
possible because then they were all
black it seemed to be okay it seemed to
be a way for painting and again I don't
want to you know tie in too much with
but you know if you were to see the
Mondrian show now I mean one of the
things about the abstraction and that
kind of painting is how landscape
derived it is and and this is only a
coincidence to me but both of the
paintings that you saw although the
Brooklyn Bridge happens to be the bridge
it's a landscape kind of painting and
painting for Johnny Stompanato is a
basically a landscape painting and this
is a landscape painting this is called a
storia and it was about the sunrise in
the morning as you'd travel on the on
the subway to have stories the one on
the left
believe it or not although it looks like
an abstract painting is actually a
portrait it's a portrait of Carl Andre
these were all I did a series of
paintings which were polygons with the
sender's dropped out and that could be a
frame and the portrait obviously could
go in the middle but I left I knew what
Carl looked like so I left it out and I
did a series of other people I did Leo
Castelli and Ileana his wife and all my
friends it was a group but actually it
was an interesting thing because I did a
octagon right after that the graphics in
started to form images which had spaces
in the middle and the one I can think of
as a Chase Manhattan Bank logo which
appeared about six weeks after my show
at Leah's announcement and then that was
a painting the later on which is again
and you can see boundaries become an
issue here in surface that's practically
the only issue but I mean it it's an
interesting way to see it and it's this
in a way relates something finding a way
to deal with the things that could come
up later or way of looking to make a
space
well this gets into another idea which
is a way of dealing with the boundaries
and the surfaces but this time the the
thing that's going to be painted or the
painting instead of being kind of self
defining becomes something that's built
and then the painting takes place on
what's built so it's a way of thinking
about the painting as not so much marks
on a surface but as as a structure as
sort of building what it is that you
want and then painting it so that is but
in order for it to work the problem with
this kind of way of working and thinking
about things is that it's not so easy to
make the painting as seeing that it
really it has to do something more than
appear to be on the surface it's a it's
it's just it's just difficult that's all
but it's a problem but I mean it also
has its kind of rewards because it's a
way to be you know at least pictorially
and graphically dramatic in a relatively
easy way yeah that's a fabricated in
aluminum and the other has that
fiberglass and that's honeycomb aluminum
and the other thing here is is treating
the surface which is it doesn't show up
much there because it was very shallow
but it was the surface was the aluminum
was etched first and then the painting
and then Incans and things were scrubbed
on the surface to give it a kind of yeah
this was the beginning of the surfboard
technology actually which ends with
which is this was the fabricated in
California and this is a taking what
we've just seen before one step farther
further I guess and it again it's a but
there are new elements and there's an
attempt here to make the surfaces move
so they're not just plane of surfaces in
relation to each other till tipped or
tilted it's a you know it's a you know
introduction of
another degree and level of complexity
now I didn't do these but this interests
me a lot and the reasons are down there
literalism illusionism boundaries and
surface and even painting in art you
know the surface here is given on the
other hand that's used and it's a very
complicated very irregular surface and
on the face of it you know we would
assume that they didn't really care that
much about the surface but let's have
the next slide it's pretty obvious on
the one on the right you know when they
go to the trouble of incising and
cutting the line in it is a tremendous
field for the surface and and and and
the given things is there's making your
and controlling your own surface by
indenting and making the relief and then
there's the use of the relief and
protrusions that are given by nature and
the surface so it it only goes to show
that that from the very beginning you
know people who know what they're doing
or care about what they're doing have a
sensitivity to the whole scene the whole
situation and the touch really and you
have to bring your own touch to the
surface but you know you need a surface
to react to in a way to it you know it
always helps I mean I think there's been
a big it's not a big problem but you can
see that the assumption of being given a
neutral or flat surface to work on is
not such a great gift as you can see
from these paintings now this is
something that we don't have anymore and
we don't have these kind of complicated
architectural surfaces to work on again
this is a given surface but it's
man-made much like surface in the caves
in Alaska and Altamira and again it's
the question of you know or the issue or
the interest
in surfaces and things that you can do
when you're given an opportunity you
know I mean things happen when there are
opportunities when there are challenges
and these are the Roman and the German
are good examples and they also serve as
pretty good reminders that you know the
degree of complexity can be quite great
and problems in dealing with them are
great too
by and large in this case most of the
solutions that we would call
scenographic and we would tend to say
well it's decorative and those things
are all true but when they're you know
there are also other examples where
these things are taken to Heights
expressive in Heights that are are truly
great and it couldn't be done any other
way yeah I mean it's hard to find a
place to look at things it's hard to
know where you are I mean it's also hard
to know who you are
but now having shown the things that we
saw running through the paintings and
the ideas some of the ideas just
skipping over the top what happens is I
mean again we talk about change which is
that at some point you take things from
the outside and you deal with them in a
kind of ordered way or you make a mark
or a drawing you try to order things you
try to organize them and then at some
point you it's it's hard not to be
interested in the things that happened
that are beyond your control and beyond
your actually imaginative ability or
just any Billy I mean for me this is
beyond my ability to comprehend it but
anyway these were actually done really
relatively recently about four or five
years ago but I started on it when I was
working on actually when I was in Elliot
house at Harvard and I was blowing smoke
rings and Harriet had gone back to the
city and I was there alone and they
heated up the room
as they do in all universities and then
they think that's warm enough they turn
off the heat and and this was a happy
moment when the heat was off and the air
was very still and it was still warm
enough blowing the smoke rings they
started to do a lot of things and they
filled up and I really could see the
smoke just because I was alone in the
room with just one light where I was
reading and blowing the smoke out and
the way they hovered as they held and
then they did what they did here which
they dropped and they sort of bifurcate
they make other smoke rings and as you
can see these are photographs actually
the fellow that you saw in there Andrew
Dunham kept saying [ __ ] all the time
when he was putting things the one who
photographed these two this was but this
was almost as unpleasant as putting the
piece in the room because the black box
was pretty hard to handle but anyway we
photographed these from six sides in a
black box and then with the with the
photograph from each side we had a cube
and then with that we could trace them
and then feed it into the computer and
get go on I think we'll see some we get
a version this is another now this is a
continuation of there's someone else
blowing a smoke ring but actually it
wasn't smoking and that's a we're making
a piece of sculpture there and I only
throw that in to show you that it's the
interest in things outside that you
really can't control molten metal is
pretty that's multiple stainless steel
and you can use it but you can't really
control it or at least we haven't found
a way to control it and again the smoke
is the same thing it sort of dissipates
itself so it's pretty hard to to get it
to do exactly what you want and so I
guess that the the interest of the
change has been in things that have
their own way of doing things that you
can be involved with you can participate
you can look at it you can see them you
can try to work with them you can try to
shape with them but it's to see if some
of those things won't give you a way to
sort of spring out to get beyond where
you were
well I don't yeah my smoke is cigar
smoke I think that that's not smoke no
that's the that's the porpoise making
believe that's a beluga whale but the
whale he yeah yeah know the ones before
we're smoked yeah but and also it was
his form that led to the shapes in the
in the paintings before which is the
Beluga movie okay I guess we can go on
okay that's the that's the net that's
the computer's version of what we saw in
the smoke
not exactly those rings but that's
that's one way we could get it and then
you all know this I mean you sure you
very for me that's just on the computer
but that's the net and open net and the
others a solid version of it what it
would be like if we were perfume bottle
now that's a painting on the right quite
similar that has the forms in and there
are two basic forms in here that there's
the smoke ring
most of those drawings are versions of
the computer drawings of the smoke rings
and there are basically two kinds
there's a there's a net and then there
are there are some two-dimensional
outlines just drawings and then then
there are some of the three-dimensional
ones with those complicated ones with
all the numbers which you all know where
our sliced versions of the solid and
then you tip them so they make kind of
dramatic drawings and the other thing of
the dots so it was a combination of the
smoke drawing and dot that the colored
images in the background and those are
enlargements of for colour printing dots
actually and on the left is some very
unsuccessful but sort of what I'm
looking for or one of the things we were
looking at I don't know how far we'll
get it was a question of making the dots
three-dimensional and of course making
the smoke rings three-dimensional and
those dots are
three dimensional dots but they're
they're derived from lumps of clay and
they're scanned and then put in the
computer it's kind of complicated and
expensive but there was the only way we
could get chunks that were what we
wanted so that's how the the chunks or
how the dots if they became
three-dimensional would relate to the
smoke rings when they became
three-dimensional so that's a whole
other problem that's either ahead of us
or maybe become forgotten I don't know
but that's another possibility compared
to the way we're doing it which is in a
relatively conventional and flat way
basically the painting represents the
drawings on paper printed on paper and
cut out they're basically these
paintings including the one that's
upstairs are basically paintings that
have some illusion in them but it's the
illusion of a collage of cut pieces of
paper that are then enlarged so that's
the piece that's upstairs when it was in
the Noda gallery on the right and then
these are flat pieces this is in the
column or Kawamura museum in Japan and
that's when we were conceiving of the
pieces as you know kind of install
murals to to relate to the actual space
that was there and this is what it as
they say turns out to be on the one hand
as a painting about a graffiti artist
and the other hand is a painting of mine
and they're not you know in the end
they're not that different but I mean
you can it's a way of making this thing
sort of move or you know the issue here
for me anyway I'm not sure what the
issue was for him it it was to make it
make it move out and one of the problems
with the graffiti not that I think that
that's either a good or a bad painting
it I don't think it's either one but it
can be very good but one of the problems
with it is that it's the same thing that
happens with me which is that you're
forced to make it on a canvas so it has
a boundary and it has it's a convention
so it's forced to become a painting the
painting on the graffiti was put in a
gallery and the guy and the kid who's
perfectly capable of handling a spray
can
with a lot of effect it would be better
on this on metal or on the side of a
moving subway car than it is on canvas
when it stops moving when it's static
and there's a problem the same problem
and I have because if it's just on a
it's just on a canvas I mean I make it
move as much as I can I do all kinds of
things but in a way you know I'm not
that satisfied with it although I like
it optically I mean I like it as
illusion but again I mean I'm still torn
I'd like it to be literal too and this
was the beginning of the idea on a
public scale this is the back this is
just painting outside on the back of a
Theatre in Toronto the Princess of Wales
Theatre and then we'll see the inside
this was the start for one reason or
another and it's the painting on the
that's I think a quarter Taurus and but
the thing about it is that it works and
it works when I when we looked at the
paintings before the graffiti painting
in my painting they had the conventional
boundaries there's something about the
imagery the smoke rings I mean I guess
it's a little bit obvious but anyway the
fact that the circular shape and the
moving around does the boundaries which
are the top and the bottom of that don't
seem to press themselves on you in the
way that they normally would the fact
that there's no that there are no side
edges that the imagery keeps moving and
keeps circulating I think is a
tremendous plus that's some detail and
and then this is these are the balcony
fronts and what's interesting about
those I think in some ways is that
they're totally abstract there's some of
the computer imagery there's some of the
forms that actually you'll see later and
some of the other things we used
everything that we used and we just made
it in relief and then cast it and the
result was it looked very ordinary
actually very uh Napster
than very much like floral decorative
design maybe from the 18th century but
the big plus was of it it was it was
acoustically very successful it's in
Toronto in a theatre called the Princess
of Wales Theatre which was a new theatre
built actually too for Miss Saigon and
now Beauty and the Beast is there yeah
this is cast aluminum the same idea like
the other things where cast plaster and
then this is a part of the theater
downstairs you know not a restaurant but
I don't know what it is a bar and that's
I mean you can see that the architecture
is not exactly flattering but you can
still carry it now one of the advantages
of this kind of imagery and this way of
dealing with things is you can sort of
fight your way through almost anything
these are big murals in the lobby and
they look nice in in the photographs
actually in the slides they're not so
red-hot when you see them they're
painted they're painted with the most
modern billboard technology available
it's a transparency that's read at a
scanned and then it's sprayed with four
colored dots on plastic but it's super
durable and it's a and it's a you know
the machine can paint that mural in
about I don't know 80 or 90 hours it
just keeps it goes night and day and
then it's done in a couple of days
well for those of you are architects I'm
sure you'll love these these are the
drawings that we made after we built a
piece that's upstairs and we made these
drawings for a gallery exhibition which
actually is going to open next week in
New York and the reason that we did it
is that we wanted to try out the idea
and we wanted to do what we couldn't do
upstairs which is to paint on both sides
of the surface so these are freestanding
sort of murals and there will be painted
on both sides and because we designed it
right into the computer we're able to
have it carved directly so that the
technology the fittings and everything
it's much smoother and much nicer than
the piece that's upstairs although I'm
not trying to denigrate that in any way
but we've made a technical aaja chol
advance since that piece was it's it's
just it's like it's really a big
surfboard I mean it's the wave and the
surfboard I guess it's the holding but
it's just really literally a big
surfboard and it's cut into sections and
they fit and it's it's pretty smooth
there are a couple of pictures of it
later I don't know I'm nice it just
works I'll have to I'll check that it's
pretty it's pretty sophisticated yeah we
can go through these I mean maybe some
people like these anyway that's okay
next but again you know they stand up so
I mean it's pretty simple it's a
rectangle on the bottom and a wavy line
drawn on the top and then you connect
two surfaces now it's like a minimal
surface
and that's what it looks like when it's
being done
that's the studio and that's those
painted oath that's those things and you
can see that it looks like a surfboard
there in the corner it is pretty good
it's pretty smooth and it's easy to work
on okay you can see how to paint while
you're talking on the telephone
you learn a lot for working and this is
the last idea this is this is what you
take an idea and you give it to an
engineer the idea is pretty simple it
was a beach hat that my kids got for me
in Rio and it's a piece of foam and
there are spirals cut out of the center
there just cuts so it's really cuts in a
two-dimensional plane but it's a
beautiful form for twisting once you cut
it I mean almost anything you do with it
looks great so let's see what that's the
same form and these this is being built
now in Antibes we tried to build it in
America by was too expensive and they
didn't want to do it but we found some
boat builders and Antibes and we found a
naval architect and what's interesting
about it is that it's exactly the same
from a technical point of view it's
exactly the same as the model the model
is a small piece of plastics intro
that's cut out and that's bent and
twisted and so we convinced these guys
to just work for us for a few months and
they laid out fiberglass on the floor
and they made the sheet so the sheet was
made with diameter about 24 feet and
then the cuts were made and then they
bent that and then they laminated balsa
wood to that and then laminated the
other surface and then took the cut so
they they literally made it the hard way
but it's actually the only way that you
can get the forms that that I know of
anyway that that are this complicated
and within some kind of reasonable kind
of expensive
the reason we had to go to this trouble
was that it's it has to be suspended and
it's in a place it's a aluminum and
glass and can't take much of a load so
we had to be under six thousand pounds
it's a roughly 20 24 foot diameter and
this is the same form seen in a two
different computer renditions of the
same idea used to make a building rather
than just a sculpture I think that might
be
well the subway car is pretty
straightforward it just moves you know
by you and depending on the speed but
it's this it's not so important what the
actually the movement is it could move
you know sideways could go this way up
and down and back and forth
but it's the sense of movement I mean
most paintings that are successful or
most paintings that you care about have
a sense of movement now by definition
painting has a serious and it's one of
the things that comes up nowadays with
literalism is you know painting is
static it doesn't move and almost
anybody can make a painting that moves
or make an object that moves and you
know one of the reasons why film is so
popular it can make a claim to being you
know more advanced or better than
painting because it moves it flickers
and it and it's better at depicting
movement you know these things are all
relative but important and I think that
you know the success of painting in the
past which is why I bring up the notion
or the problem of illusionism has been
its success at being a static art that
implies movement in a convincing way you
know I don't want to play with words I
mean but the literal movement within the
picture the action whatever is depicted
it takes place and you know the
emotional substance of it I mean you are
moved in a way to but I think that they
have to come together that's really what
you know when we say a painting is great
that's really what we're talking about
it seems vital to us and there's a kind
of movement in an unreal situation after
all it's static and at the same time we
are moved the interior our interior our
consciousness our feelings and
everything I moved so there's these two
kinds of movement neither of which are
quantifiable in any way I mean you can't
really very well describe or it doesn't
mean what
to say I feel this or I feel that
because how do you know what the other
person knows he doesn't really know very
much about what you feel or what it
means to you you can say you know I feel
sad but you know these are not very
exacting and it's the same way about the
sense of how successful a movement is
within the picture so you have but these
things still nonetheless is difficult as
they are to deal with it seems to me
anyway pretty clear that they are what
what painting both is and is about I can
guarantee that however there's a person
sitting four rows back you who are
expert on Melville but the title comes
from a Melville novel which I haven't
read and I make no apologies in fact
when we went to a Melville symposium you
know we all live in our own little
worlds as they say but a woman came up
to me was so happy that I had done she
expected me to do for Melville for Marti
for what I done for Moby Dick I mean I
just spent five years working on Moby
Dick and she want me to spend another
five or six years working on Marty so
see if I could resurrect it because she
felt it was a very underappreciated
effort but that wasn't my goal and it's
not going to be my goal
I don't think my experience with
architects has been pretty grim but but
I think yes I mean I think it's I think
it's possible I mean you know we
basically you get the job after the
architect has done what he's done and so
if I want to work with an architect I
mean I'll hire them I mean but I want to
I mean I mean I can make the building it
you could you could cooperate I mean but
the problems are it's not nothing is
very conducive to it I mean the whole
scheme for building is you know so
obvious and so complicated at the same
time that they're really I mean then the
main problem is is not just for the
architects and the artists working
together it's really a problem for the
architects too few if any architects
that I know of in recent time Frank
Gehry tries it once in a while are able
to change anything in other words you
know you're committed to a building
scheme after the plan is you and that's
it it's over I mean you can see what
mistakes you made but you can't do
anything about it
you know and nothing changes I mean
gaudi's the last one I can think of a
nervy was pretty good at it but Gaudi
nervy those people could make things
happen and make things change kibou za
did it in some of the houses I mean you
know but I mean you know architects are
no different from anybody else I mean
they don't get it all right the first
time I mean as we well know
I don't know they probably is it's
probably true that way I mean I mean you
know but it's a small world I mean and
there's a lot of building and there are
a few architects who you know have a
sense of themselves and what they can do
and what arts about that they can you
know maybe only a few architects can
really afford to bring people in to do
the jobs I mean you know there isn't
much left in the budget most of the work
that gets done is well know is from the
few jobs that are mandated you know the
budget didn't complain about that I mean
I made a building for the project I
didn't have it here for Dresden and
Philip Johnson built it and is his
gatehouse in New Canaan and it was a
monstrous masterpiece I mean but it was
only the shell of what we did we never
worked on the fenestration or the roofer
anything like that but the form he was
able to build it and blow it up it
seemed to work okay
Mississippi Missouri welcome painting
yeah it was a the painting didn't move I
mean the painting yeah moved is you you
rolled up one end and unroll the other
and you moved it across but it's still I
mean I don't know there are a lot of
ways of looking at it but I mean the
basic thing is you make a mark you act
and you make a mark and that's it it
stays there it doesn't move after you
you know you can't keep the paint moving
after it dries or you know I mean that's
it I mean you could I mean you could
make it slippery there there are a lot
of things you could do but it's not it
would be both complicated and difficult
and although you see a lot of that in
installations and stuff I remember Bob
rauschenberg did a piece for art and
technology which was a big steel box
with mud and hot water in it in the
bubbling mud it was certainly a good as
an idea it sounds better than it looked
I mean you get tired of the
but you know I mean that you can say
that paintings guitar me but I'm just it
just raises the issue I mean it's a good
way of seeing it I mean it's that the
the point about painting is and the and
but painting also has a pass and has the
history I mean it has I don't know if
it's the convention that we accept and
that we like or they really did it right
you know sometimes it happens in the
right way and it's convincing and it's
okay and then when you bring up the
issue like having the boiling mud it's
sort of interesting to bring up the
issue and it gets your attention and
then but you know does it carry it does
it hold as much as the you know non
bubbling works I understand working
space you're very interested in
Caravaggio I believe in how we see these
frescoes and palaces and churches and
things like this and the the theater in
Toronto where you into the building
decoration do you find that you end up
wishing that things look more like they
did in the 1600s a instead of the we
modernist look of say 10 to 50 which
tend to you know I mean I can't I'm not
gonna I'm not sure what what was the
point of what this car of odd you have
to do basically I mean I have the
reasons for Caravaggio had different
from the general reason which is the
Baroque I mean which is the reason I was
drawn to it or interested in it was a
matter of change I mean you know for the
in my working life as it were you know
for 10 to 15 years you know making
things quote literal direct and simple
seem to have a tremendous virtue and you
know I just didn't I didn't find it
convincing and it's nice to look to
something I mean it you know it wasn't
just what everybody said it wasn't you
know it wasn't all that great and it
wasn't but I don't think that's as
important as it wasn't going anywhere
and I'm not saying that this way of
working raining is necessarily going
anywhere
it is different and to me anyway the the
painting in itself and the way it
relates to both the architecture and the
sculpture seems to me anyway a pretty
fruitful way of working and you know if
I look at what I've done and what I'm
doing I have to say well it may not be
that great but it's you know it's not
it's not boring me to death
that actually they move vertically and
yeah well I'm not sure exactly what
you're saying but one of the things is
true one of the senses that you you that
you there's no way of getting which is
really beautiful about the smoke is that
first of all it goes in the direction
that you send it
but then when it hovers when it stops it
then creates its own sense of dropping
out and as it drops it forms you know
again depending on all kinds of things
like the temperature and currents and
air currents theory and that has its own
kind of you know really compelling
dynamism which I like I'm not going to
get that in the painting I'm not worried
about that but the idea is that maybe in
some way which is not you know not that
clears I mean one way or the other I get
something like that that's what I'm
gonna settle for and I'll be quite happy
if I get a little closer
you do what do they do and how do you
feel about well I can tell you what they
feel they feel they do everything and I
and I yeah and I make a mess of all
their really good ideas but you know you
have to learn to live with it
we they all are tremendously talented
they do a really good job and they do
things I can't do and they have a lot of
good ideas but I like some of my ideas
too and you know it's you you just work
it out just keep banging away it's uh
the biggest thing that the only reason
that they stay is because of the
opportunities I mean because we do work
on new ideas there are things to do and
they can get to run off by themselves
and do what they want to do that they
couldn't do otherwise but if it weren't
for that they would be long gone I
guarantee you was painted was way it's
supposed to be as far as I'm concerned
the client would like it to be more
colorful his decorator his color
consultant told him that it should be
gold with pastel tints but but but we
made it white with color on the edges
and Kevin Roche said he made me swear on
the Bible that it could only be white I
couldn't ruin the space and everything
just can't have color in there it just
has to be pure white I said fine I want
it to be white so then that so then the
client comes in he says you know Kevin
says it really should be very colorful
there
so anyway anyway it's a compromise it
has color on the edges in white on you
know 80% of it but to form that piece I
mean should be white I mean and I don't
I don't know I mean I could work on it
more and I probably will the color on
the edges is not it's not the wrong idea
it's just it's not that easy to get it
right
and get it to Singapore in 20 days but
you know that form is you know it could
be in the painting or it could be a
relief or something like that but right
now that that form seems to be pretty
straightforward it's a it's a sculptural
form and it works
I think it's tremendous and I think it
has I think it'll work as an
architectural form too
I mean I know it will I mean it's just a
question of the expense building it
architectural is difficult and but the
real problem is not that the forms could
be built I mean if it were you know for
a band shell and Rio de Janeiro you
could build it in ten minutes
but if you're gonna put it in you know
in Bangor Maine you got a you got a seal
it's gotta be weather weather tight is a
pretty severe test for those kind of
forms and that the painting actually
starts so is in fact boundaries just as
much a part of the illusion as the
surfaces with you a hundred hundred
percent or one hundred and fifty percent
that I think is the point that I most
wanted to make is that they you know
it's it there it's the relation of the
things to each other and their ability
to expand and to form you know in a way
something else to change the space to
change things to change your perception
of it and how you feel about it
[Music]
well I have some of those paintings I
showed we're paintings on flat surfaces
and I think they were pretty good but
they have a problem that they're not so
good unless they have a lot of shadow a
lot of illusionism and the trompe l'oeil
is sort of against my religion so it's a
it's a real conflict so I you know it
was a way of doing it and getting the
idea and seeing what it does but I don't
think that I would be happy with it well
I like to think that didn't I mean you
can't you can't nail everything down but
I mean I'm not seeking ambiguity for its
own sake there sometimes things seem
ambiguous and sometimes that's a that's
a plus but it's not it's not a goal and
neither really is complexity but
ambiguity and complexity and I don't
think I was worth that you know a pretty
necessary ingredient so you you know the
question is you know to to deal with
them and have them you know that's the
job that's where the art part comes in
you have to pull it together
transformations and the computer gives
you an opportunity to generate continual
not to watch it I can afford you could
spend a sabbatical at MIT for a while
have you thought of actually
constructing the artwork on a computer
or do you consider it only a tool for
the use yeah I I see it only as a tool
and I only really liked one thing about
it which is the most simple and obvious
thing the ability to rotate the thing in
space and to really sort of move it
around there stretching and pulling and
all the complicated things you can do
with it I can do that with the model
anyway and I can even turn the model but
it's nice to be able to see it it's it's
it's a very useful tool I was very
unhappy with my experience the reason we
started using a computer in the first
place was to help us build things and
that was a complete disaster it's
worthless as a tool for building
anything so at least on the level that
you can afford so I don't know I mean
you can you can build anything you want
using a computer if you build it make
one thing it costs a fortune you do that
ten thousand or a hundred and fifty
thousand times it's a perfectly useful
tool but for doing it once and changing
it immediately and doing something
different it's a it's a nightmare but
also as I've talked about with some
other people the issue I mean the thing
that I'm interested in I suppose is what
a lot of other people are just the smoke
certainly I'd like to put on the
computer and then see how it would
change on the you know conditions of
heat wind humidity and whatnot but since
if you know a way to do it you can let
me know since it's all particles it's
kind of expensive to map them whatever
you do in the computer put most recent
work seems to be on the birds
what is your feeling about kinetic art
as it was done a long time ago and still
being done by others no I don't have
anything against kinetic art I mean but
you know one of the problems with it is
that it it's the problem of literalism
it is what it is and it does what it
does and it tends to lack a kind of
magic you know that seems to be inherent
illusion but I don't I don't have
anything against it in fact I own some
but you know I think it's possible I
mean there are a lot of things you could
do but one of the problems with you know
from a practical point of view movements
a difficult problem because you know
it's in it's a question of how much you
want a program and how much you want to
control and then what you want to do I
don't you know I think you know it's
going to be more of it artwork but there
are compromises that painting on
flexible surfaces say yeah we tried to
build a building with Teflon and they've
got hysterical so but I mean lots of
other people doing look I think it it's
it's perfectly possible yeah I mean I
love I mean I wanted to use mirrored
mylar too I mean there are a lot of
materials out there there are a lot of
things that you can do but then the
question becomes you know how do you
program or control the movement what's
what's the movement gonna be is it kind
of flutter in the breeze or not I mean
you know what's what's the move
okay maybe there's a confusion I'm not a
confusion I mean it's my own fault but
it's okay
movement is one thing okay and so it's
literal movement it does this or it does
that but the heart of the matter is not
as much the movement as it is the action
okay it's what's depicted it's what's
happening and it's what makes painting
great whether it's abstract or real is
how is how you perceive that how you
relate to that to the action to the
movement to the kind of movement that it
is how it's informed what it's doing
it's not just the movement I mean the
movement is a way of describing it but
it's really basically the action which
is the action the subject whatever it is
let me what I would like to do is ask
you and when one final broad question
say where do you go from here what do
you see is the most exciting things to
explore and what what are the ideas that
really animate you right now for your
new work well the hardest thing in the
most interesting thing to me is to keep
going on all as I described before which
was the point of the diagram setting
which was to you know deal with fine it
art as an enterprise and to be able to
work you know but it's hard to be able
to order to afford whatever want to say
yeah and also in terms of energy as well
as all the other things to see with to
keep working on basically the three
areas more or less at the same time I
mean and to see where it gets me I don't
I don't I guess what I want to say is I
don't want to drop any one of the three
in particular and it doesn't matter to
me about architecture if I don't you
know if I have to see Philips version of
it but I mean I know it's you know just
to keep working on the ideas on the
models and the projects and to keep
thinking about it I guess thank you
[Applause]